to my cigarette.
>> How long have you been here?
>> Joe and I smoke him
>> and I I used to think he said it clearly
smoking kills and it's like someone
coming with a knife to kill you and say
here take money thank you for coming.
You know what I'm saying?
>> But you know that's why Allah never left
things up our feelings or our own
conclusions because there are different
feelings. You know what I'm saying? So
record things some sometimes a lot
ofation goes against our desires but
guess what? It's good for us. according
to whatever Allah taugh us to do is good
for us. Whatever Allah told us to stay
away from was better for us. Sometimes
there is some goodness in it but even
over goodness and sometimes Allah told
us to stay
away from something even there is good
like I said but it's evil over
collectively that point the person who's
given who who one person benefits
everyone else is suffering. Islam says
no no no no no individually.
>> Yeah. And the most aspect of Islam is
the one that support is like you know
Christianity or Judaism or other
religions you need to go through someone
to go some they believe in but they have
like a lot of god has to go through this
through that god created you so you go
to him directly. However you need a way
to worship God. That's why you
how to worship Allah. If I need to pray
to Allah or to God, I don't have to go
to Muhammad. I just raise my hand. Oh,
God help me. I pray five times a day.
You understand? Even like look, I love
the government like the lifestyle we
live in. Everything is easy for us.
Literally, I can be sitting in my own
room. I can order the food, clothes,
fridge, everything. But the depression
and and the suicide was going too high.
>> Let me ask you whether you know you do
not know.
>> Sure. We're going to go there.
They said the most happiest countries in
the world are two countries. You know
what are they?
>> No funny up the country that they claim
to be the most happiest country in the
world is Sweden and Japan. But guess
what? In Sweden and Japan the the r the
rates of suicide is so high how they
happen suicide rates in Japan and
company were higher than in Syria in
2014 with that civil war.
>> Wow.
>> So how they happy? Because they get good
salary. So the lifestyle meaning that
we're looking from physical point of
view
>> and sister there's something in our
heart regardless how much we try to
fulfill that emptiness by simple drugs
by doing fornication by drinking alcohol
by going to nightclub you will never
fulfill it except when you recognize the
creator and worship him and following
my lifestyle you know I had to learn the
hard way for me to change my lifestyle I
had to go to prison but so Before I was
doing all type of craziness just to make
myself happy. Yes, I used to get happy
by smoking draw here and there. But it's
temporary happiness. But the real
happiness and the true happiness and the
ultimate happiness is when you recognize
your purpose of life and you worship
your creator according to his teach.
Does it make sense?
>> Yeah. No, it's I think it's really
beautiful.
>> Sorry. So what is what is your belief
system? Sorry.
>> Um I come from like a pic like health.
Oh, you come today.
So you ask, you are the real English.
>> Oh, no English.
>> What about the real English people are?
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> So, so, so what I would say to you like
if you brother to I believe if you
accept should be g to your creator. But
now the question is how do you know your
way is correct? Because that's why I
will say to you later on in order for us
to watch the creator I'm not going to
watch the creator do what I feel because
you have different feeling than mine. So
which feeling is correct? That's why the
creator based upon his wisdom and even
left our feelings. He sent prophet
Muhammad, Jesus, Moses, you know me, I
came from North Africa. All right? Some
of my ancestors, they were polit. But
I'm not going to follow their ways
because they are my forefathers. No, cuz
Allah gave me my own internet. You
understand? Even Prophet Muhammad was
say Islam is Arab culture. But when
prophet Muhammad came to Islam to the
Arabs, they rejected it because they
knew that's not Arab culture. Is it goes
against their own culture, you
understand? In Islam, there's no problem
to be proud of your culture. I mean,
you're happy you have a culture and
everything as long as they're not
opposed the creator's teaching. So, some
of our cultures came from the devil
worshippers and from other than from the
evil ones. So, as a human beings, when
you add them human beings, you should
reflect okay, I want to worship my
creator. So how do you know this is the
correct way? That's why Islam is not
based upon feelings and personific
experience. Yes, perfect experience can
help you but doesn't my always has to be
truth. Islam is based upon universal
proof as the brothers explained about
prophecies.
How men existed 1,400 years ago who
couldn't read and write is coming to
tell us about
systemic
way of life which is good for us
individually collectively. While on the
other hand, we have this specialist and
experts that to deal with the problems
and everything and you don't know how to
to resolve it because the creator knows
everything in detail and he knows what
is good for you in detail and what is
bad for you in detail and how Allah
communicates with us through his
prophets and messengers Jesus, Moses,
Abraham, Noah, Jacob, Isaac and the last
of the prophet Muhammad. You understand?
So like I said to you the most as the
most important aspect of Islam is the
oneness of God the purity
the oneness of God you know even prophet
Muhammad we're not allowed to bow down
to prophet Muhammad we're not allowed to
liberate prophet Muhammad a man came to
prophet Muhammad this deseration
he bow down to him and he said what are
you doing he said oh messenger of Allah
I was in Yemen and I saw Christians
bowing down to the priest and he said no
you don't bow down to no one except to
your creator
So I don't know if it shows you some
examples to show you why prophet
Muhammad cannot be a liar. You know when
someone claim to be prophet of God
that's the biggest claim because you
claim to be God the most high chosen you
to convey his message. So either he's
mentally unstable or he wants to gain
something from his life okay or he's
deluded which is mentally unstable. But
when you study the biography of the
prophet Muhammad wasallam like I
mentioned even non-Muslims historians
they would tell you this man was very
smart
>> was very intelligent. So we move that
he's mentally delusional
and stable. So was he did he claim to be
prophet of God because he wants to gain
something from his life? No. Clearly he
had like he was in charge of many h
places in the Arab peninsula. when his
daughter came to him, she said, "I want
servant to to help me with the stuff at
home."
What you do? Remember Allah and I will
give you power by remembering him. So
remember to prophet of God, if he's just
lying, he's going to try to utilize
anything to manipulate the people to
misuse them, take their wealth and
everything. But prophet Muhammad even
though he was in charge of the Allah pen
before he passed away his house he had
like a little prayer little mistake on
even his companion Omar saw him he say
oh messenger of God choose you you are
the messenger of the creator of
everything the king of everything and
you are sleeping on a mat which left a
mark on your ch on your body and the the
king of the Persians and the Romans they
have everything in his life. So he said,
"Oh, Omar, would you not be happy to
have this life and have the hereafter
paradise eternal?" But that doesn't mean
you should not work in this life. It
doesn't mean you should not take care of
yourself. But this life regardless how
much you stay here. Even 100 years,
you're going to die one day. You know
how many people left the house, they
never come back. How many people went to
sleep, they never wake up? when your
family that love you so much they'll put
you in the grave and they will leave you
by yourself in that grave which all of
us will be there that's why the prophet
Muhammad was said visit the graveyard
because it reminds you the reality of
this life but also it reminds you of the
hereafter to prepare yourself to meet
the creator what do you think so far
makes sense yeah I think it honestly
thank you so much
>> you're welcome very much
I know
>> we got
Yeah. And
>> I know you guys at the moment like this
so much.
>> Oh, you know why? Let me ask you why.
>> Because people don't like anything that
is white and Christian.
>> Anything that's not white Christian. You
know that's one thing but one thing but
I'll tell the other mention to you
cuz majority of people try to make bad
those who are in authority. Okay. And
those who are in authority are
benefiting from our suffering. How
gambling is allow interest is best for
us is allowing alcohol is better for us
is allowed for us allow them for all of
this. So
when Islam say don't do it not because
Islam hate you or Allah hates you not
because Allah wants good for you to make
so those who are in power are benefiting
from these things devices. So they're
going to look at Islam direct from their
own business. So imagine I I own Cardiff
and I have a nice clubs I have bars I
have what they call it of license. I
have gambling place. I have banks and
you come along as a Muslim teaching
people that gambling is forbidden
fornication. I'm going to be happy with
you if I'm going to listen to you. So
what I'm going to do because I'm a rich
man, I'm going to utilize my money to
make you to make you look bad. Even
though you are a good person, you want
good for the people. That's why there is
a huge war against Islam cuz the only
religion that is standing firm and is
not backing down this evil people and
evil agenda and this hidden societies
and secret organizations is Islam
because Islam connected to your creator.
That's why one of the poets said he said
they flee from being the servant of the
creator and they become slaves of their
own desires but just being a member you
know not because whatever we desire we
should do. Islam controls you discipline
like I said Islam teaches you to have
connection how to have relationship with
your creator. Okay. Islam teaches you
how to have connection with your own
parents with your husband or with the
wife or with the children with with the
with the with the with the neighbors
even with your enemies. Islam teach us
even your enemies be just with them.
Don't lie against them. Don't oppress
them you know cuz you know from human
nature you want to if someone slap you
want to kill him but that's that is not
justice you just slap you. So that's why
there are there's a huge war with Islam
on one of the main reason. So I would
say to you sister you want to worship
the creator be grateful I advise I
invite you to Islam become Muslim
worship God you know that's invite you
>> no you don't need to be baptized but you
don't need to be
understand
that is you do it for your is a slave in
the last ent.
>> You know, I always mention I don't know
if you mention about the house.
>> I always mention this.
>> Imagine you are in your own room and you
wake up at night and there's a fire
everywhere and you try your best to save
yourself but you couldn't. You gave up.
So I came and I saved your life. What
would you say to me at least?
>> Thank you.
>> Would you remember me all the time?
>> Of course I saved your life. So why are
you not grateful and remember the
creator gave you life for free? The life
that we have is so dear to us. If
someone come to shoot us, we'll try to
do everything to protect our life. The
creator gave it to you for free. You
know, while we speaking, we are
benefiting from the creator's creation.
Oxygen in out. May Allah forbid if you
have to go to the hospital and they have
to give you oxygen, they will charge you
money, you know, but you're getting it
for free in out for free. Also, now
going to say, you know what, I want to
be grateful to my creator. I want to
worship him. Then the second question I
will ask you if you want to buy a gift
for your mother would you buy a gift
that you love or your mother love?
Likewise if you want to worship the
creator and you want to be grateful to
him should do it the way he loves
because the way he loves is objective.
The way we love is subjective. And this
is in summary the two testimony of Islam
when someone become Muslim there's no
one worthy of worship except Allah. Oh
Allah the creator of everything. I want
to be grateful to you. I want to worship
you according to who? According to his
last prophet Muhammad. If I was alive at
the time of Jesus, I would say there's
no one worthy of worship except Allah.
And Jesus is the Messiah and the
messenger of Allah. Before Jesus, Moses.
Before Moses, Jacob, Isaac, Abraham,
Noah, all of them came to teach us how
to worship God. And like I said to you,
when someone become Muslim, now you have
a clear vision. What is your purpose of
life and how to worship creator? That's
why you know always I invite people to
become Muslim. And like Islam like the
brother mentioned when you Islam and
translate when you translate in English
means submission means submit yourself
to God. Hinduism to an area Buddhism to
Buddha. Christianity to Christ. You with
me? Islam is submission to the creator.
>> You understand?
>> Thank you very much. Let me give you
something to read.
All right. Do you have Do you have any
questions?
>> Take care of yourself. Have a nice
weekend. Thank you. Think about it,
please. Think about it.
[laughter]
Yeah.
>> And these are some of the, you know,
conversations that we have with
non-Muslims which are in theory
beneficial. You know, it's just about
planting that seed in their heart
spiritually so that they can walk away
inshallah with something to think about,
something to ponder about, something to
reflect over. The proofs and evidences
for Allah are found within horizons,
found [music] within revelation, and
also found within, you know, the makeup
of our own selves. You know, you look at
your hands, you look at the creation and
how your fashions and your modules,
these are all proofs of a creator. So
this is what we do in a bit busy now.
But this is the whole reason why we do
da keep pushing, keep trying and
wherever you are
you all successam.
So the conclusion is alhamdulillah we
speak to this lady the brother Ahmed
speaking to her before me by the way had
it first.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I came spoke to both of
us. Alhamdulillah will explain to her.
>> Yeah.
>> Alhamdulillah. We ask God to guide us to
Islam. Amen.
>> And you know that's that I mentioned
this many times. When he speaks to
people with open heart and open mind,
>> they will never tell you Islam doesn't
make any sense.
>> Why? Because the one that sent down
Islam is the same one who create us.
>> So Allah when you it's like me. If I
make a car, I'm going to make make sure
to make a key that fit in the car.
>> Yeah. So it runs properly.
>> It runs properly. You see? So that's why
Christianity teach literally you have to
do wrestling with your own brain to
accept the teaching but Islam the
foundation okay it's so clear cuz some
people might say but there's some
Islamic legisation which I don't
understand you know why you have problem
with it with those legisation because
you try to connect them to liberalism
which have nothing to do with liberalism
or other philosophical ideologies but if
you connect those legisation to the
foundation of Islam makes perfect sense
>> amen yellow pack.